rojo la líder de una red contra
revolucionaria y director del sitio web
contrarrevolucionario a man news fue
ahorcado esta mañana ahorcado por hablar
en contra de la república islámica de
irán rojo la samp fue declarado culpable
de los 13 cargos en su contra incluyendo
corrupción en la tierra un delito
capital insultar la santidad del islam
delitos contra la seguridad interna y
externa y el espionaje en nombre del
servicio de inteligencia francés porque
rojo la samp vivió en el exilio en
francia durante varios años incluso
tenía el estatus de refugiado
teherán lo acusó de ser un espía que
también contaba con el apoyo de los
servicios secretos estadounidenses e
israelíes en su juicio confesó
concesiones leídas y filmadas y cuya
credibilidad es cuestionable espero
arabia saudita y los emiratos árabes
unidos- me han pedido que coopere con
ellos también me han ofrecido una buena
suma de dinero antes de irak un amigo
mío en malasia ofreció establecer una
red con la inversión de adele bin ahmed
al jubeir el ex ministro de relaciones
exteriores saud y tribales
una red en la plataforma de mensajería
encriptada telegram
de esta manera irán acusa al ex
periodista de haber desempeñado un papel
activo en las protestas del invierno
[Aplausos]
las protestas contra el alto costo de la
vida que rápidamente tomaron un giro
político según teherán rojo la samp fue
arrestado de octubre de 2019 por los
guardias revolucionarios entonces estaba
en irak la república islámica no
especificó el lugar la fecha o las
circunstancias de la detención sólo
estas imágenes de él con los ojos
vendados en la parte de atrás de un
coche fueron emitidas reporteros sin
fronteras reaccionó rápidamente a la
noticia de la muerte del periodista en
su cuenta de 'twitter' sorprendido de
que el poder judicial iraní llevará a
cabo la sentencia